do you did you know SBF you ever meet
him uh I interviewed him before and
what'd you think what was your takeaway
seriously in the moment what'd you think
of this guy my interaction with him was
I don't know maybe two years ago a year
and a half ago whatever he was just like
a normal dude I mean I've interviewed a
bunch of these people right so like
there was nothing at the time where it
was like oh this is like crazy but I
think also I saw somebody put a uh like
a montage where when he first started
back in 2018 2019 then a couple years
later a couple years later like there's
physical differences there's like you
could just tell like he's kind of just
like a little bit more agitated and so
you got to remember that like if you
take a snapshot of somebody at one point
in time it's not the same person that
they are you know a year two years later
whatever and I think what's crazy is
that like this dude was on stage at a
conference with all kinds of big names
celebrities and politicians all that
stuff the media I mean he put them on
the front cover of article of uh
magazines being like he's the next
Warren Buffett so it's like it isn't one
single group that I think is responsible
right it's not uh the users who trusted
him it's not the investors it's not also
the media that exalted them the media
right and so like in some way in
hindsight it's very obvious where people
are like oh [ __ ] of course but like to
your point did you pick up on it all
when you were interviewing them no and
like do you wear that stupid Tech outfit
where you act like you don't know how to
dress did he do that
I hate it it is I'm in the network what
is it called the social media you know
how to dress you're not a [ __ ] idiot
I was just a chest high on Zoom uh oh
you zoomed them yeah zoomed them so I
think the other thing uh that's kind of
crazy about it though is like the
reports that are coming out is this
wasn't like the whole company knew this
either so everyone there's people
working there and they were in like um
focused on the users right the users
lost money that's bad that's not good uh
there's a lot of other people who got
burnt that are kind of on the periphery
but also you gotta remember there's a
lot of employees these even if it's only
200 employees or whatever that work at
these companies and they're in shock
like there's reports and they're shocked
they're ashamed they're like all this
stuff and it's almost like uh they're
let down as well now again people aren't
going to be sympathetic to them
that's on your resume FTX films how do
you get another job and many of them had
funds on the platform yeah it means that
like there's just a lot of collateral
damage for this stuff uh and I think
that it's just there's no winners
there's no winners that's the thing man
it's so tricky because nobody has any
empathy for people who lose money in
crypto I don't know why we have way more
empathy for people who lose money in the
stock market I guess we feel like
there's like more work that goes into
that but
yeah like when you lose we've accepted
the stock market as a thing yeah it
seems like a real job with this other
one like we all have friends that were
idiots and then made tons of money
but like meme stocks and like crypto
have been put in the same bucket and I
think the narrative is just like always
young kids who are like stupid who are
like uh gambling yes right and so like
you if you're a professional or you're
an adult you're like I don't feel bad if
people lose money gambling so you never
[ __ ] with any of the other coins at
all no I started out mining ethereum
right I didn't even know anything nobody
ever told me about Bitcoin or any stuff
so like I don't think there's very many
people who just learn about Bitcoin
never look at anything else learn about
anything else whatever I think actually
what happens is most people they're like
What's this crypto thing they learn
about a bunch of different stuff yeah
and at some point they're like oh
Bitcoin is different than the other
things right and then they eventually
kind of flow that way and if you look
like there's lots of coins that went up
in value
three or four years later they're gone
they're replaced by other ones but
Bitcoin has just remained the number one
for 15 years because in my opinion it's
the one that has the most kind of
sustainable resilient value over time
and you had said that so Larry David had
endorsed them in like a Super Bowl
commercial Tom Brady had backed them
financially and apparently I think you
would say that Larry David is getting
like they're trying to sue him class
action lawsuits class action guys
against a lot of people and Steph Curry
a bunch of them so why are they being
prosecuted and why are they being
prosecuted faster than bankman uh I I
don't think it's prosecution for what I
understand it's like lawyers right like
kind of civil stuff who's got money that
I can sue they got you will they get any
money from that I don't know how that
stuff works what's gonna happen with
bankman freed and the nerd girl yeah
what are the what are the charges
against him like what could he get I I
don't know because also it like they're
not in the United States they're in the
Bahamas like you start getting into like
this weird world of just like if you're
an international
uh legal person you probably understand
it but also there's other people who
have gotten in trouble or accused of
trouble through this whole downturn like
over the summer and stuff and like
they're not in the U.S so like what
happens to them there's one guy who uh I
think it's the country of Singapore
maybe uh that keeps saying like yo we
have a we're looking for him he keeps
tweeting he's like no you're not
like he's like I'm not aware of that
like I'm gonna go to this event if
you're looking for me I'll be here like
there's like crazy stuff right with
Mount Cox that anyone get in trouble
with that situation uh that's a good
question I I don't think anyone actually
got in trouble uh because it wasn't a
situation where uh from my understanding
it's like there was like accusations of
Fraud and stuff like that I could be
wrong on that um I think it was more of
just like it was a poorly run business
and there was one guy who sold it to
another guy and then like that guy
probably ran it even worse it sounds
like so just kind of uh didn't work as a
business went bankrupt and then it was
like okay who has assets left but I
don't think there's accusations like
there are yeah if he's in the states
though what could his charges be like
fraud
oh I mean you kind of look at a spectrum
right like the people who are most
sympathetic to him would probably
describe it as like the guy made a
mistake that's what he's saying right uh
the people who are the biggest critics
are like yo you know a million plus
users
is bigger than you know Madoff I don't
think had a million people not even
right now he may have had more AUM I
think he had more than 10 billion or
something I don't remember the exact
details so it's like I don't know how
it's gonna play out right and then also
like another piece of it right and I've
been getting a lot of heat online people
are like oh you did an advertising deal
with like the media company stuff and
we're like we had a framework it was
like all right we're gonna work with
us-based regulated exchanges yeah like
seems pretty you know simple framework
to use